[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video we're gonna be discussing
Wormtail aka Peter Pettigrew warm tail
gets a really bad rap and has arguably
the worst reputation of the entire
franchise with perhaps the exception of
umbrage no one not even warm tails
allies held him in a very high regard
and one of the reasons that people look
down on him was if they saw him as
submissive and weak Voldemort and the
Death Eaters disrespected him never
truly giving him the time of day warm
tail was instrumental in Voldemort's
resurgence so it's a testament to
Voldemort sinister nature and warm tales
submissive nature that he could
disrespect him so openly at one point
warm tail was sent to Snape's house to
assist him but Snape ended up treating
him like his servant a supreme gesture
of disrespect I was under the impression
the Dark Lord sent you here to assist me
to assist you yes yes but not to serve
you drinks and to claim your house
Wormtail was a British pure blood wizard
born in 1959 or 1960 he had pale skin
unhealthy hair that was constantly
falling out and blue eyes he was a
sniveling excuse for a man whose
loyalties only lay where there was power
and he did not value friendship or love
in the way that most do despite serving
both sides of the battle at one point or
another
neither respected him and those that
warm tail betrayed hated him because he
was morally an awful awful person and
while I agree with the sentiment that
warm tail was a despicable person
morally I am NOT of the impression that
he was an untalented wizard in my
opinion warm tail is one of the most
underrated characters in the franchise
power wise as if we break everything
down we can see that he was actually
able to achieve quite a lot magically
was he the most powerful wizard of all
time definitely not but were there worse
wizards than him certainly many witches
and wizards wrote off his magical
ability due to his appearance and meek
demeanor the truth is that Pettigrew was
a talented wizard but he was also
equally mentally weak and impressionable
sure Pettigrew didn't perform well at
school but this could have been for
any number of reasons and everyone knows
that many people struggle in their
respective fields in their formative
years it's entirely possible that he was
just a late bloomer I think that it
would be safe to say that Pettigrew's
friends never truly respected him and
viewed him as a little bit beneath him
despite being the good guys after years
and years of being dismissed and not
taken seriously Pettigrew simply hit a
breaking point a point at which he
sought power independent from those that
he knew when he turned to Voldemort
Pettigrew saw an opportunity to become
his own man
Voldemort probably saw that he was
decent at magic but also mentally weak
and he took advantage of that James
Sirius and Lupin were ultimately good
people but they were also arrogant jerks
in their youth and Pettigrew who was
perpetually looked down upon by them
eventually made a choice as awful as it
was to betray them his tale could easily
be an allegory for bullying and the
bullied kid going down the wrong path
Pettigrew grew up in the shadows of
others had historical circumstances been
just a little bit different it's not out
of the question that he might have
really flowered into more of an
independent environment just a few years
later at last free of the rather pompous
and arrogant friends with which he'd
spent his teenage years while at school
Professor McGonagall expressed that
Peter was less talented than his friends
going as far as to say that he was
hopeless at dueling and while serving
Lord Voldemort he too denoted him as a
poor wizard but among his childhood
companions to Marauders there really
wasn't much of an indication that he was
significantly less talented than any of
them and the other three serious black
James Potter and Remus Lupin were all
very talented wizards in fact Wormtail
would go on to become far more versed in
the dark arts than any of them opening
up and expanding his magical arsenal and
taking it to another level altogether so
why does warm tail get such a bad rap JK
Rowling herself said the following on
this matter it turned out that he was a
better wizard than they knew referring
to the Marauders the truth is that when
Peeta was truly pushed he was able to
accomplish a lot let's take a look at
some of his accomplishments with help
from the other Marauders Peter was able
to become
magus at the early age of 15 Hogwarts
Transfiguration professor Minerva
McGonagall only achieved this feat at
the age of 17 and she was under direct
instruction from Transfiguration master
Albus Dumbledore this really speaks to
how impressive this feat was despite
having been helped by his friends at the
Haggadah school of magic is school known
for its intensive focus on self
Transfiguration students become anime
guy by the age of 14
Peter attending a regular magical school
with no particular focus on
Transfiguration achieve this just one
year older than that Peter was of course
an unregistered animagus meaning that he
did not report his animagus status to
the Ministry of Magic something that all
anime guy are meant to do this allowed
him to abuse his ability
Dumbledore phrased it well when he said
that anime guy are usually people who
seek to avoid punishment when they broke
the law in his animagus form Pettigrew
hid from the order of the Phoenix Death
Eaters and the ministry he was even able
to falsify his death after escaping
serious after Voldemort's first defeat
he was able to successfully frame him
for his crimes then faked his own death
simultaneously killing twelve people
with one curse after this he lived for
years in his animagus form a rat
Pettigrew stayed in his animagus form
for 12 whole years something that I
can't imagine was an easy feat and
became the Weasleys family pet rat
Scabbers in addition to becoming an
animagus
which is an advanced form of
Transfiguration Pettigrew was also first
in conjuration another extremely
advanced branch of Transfiguration
conjuration which allows individuals to
transfigure an object out of thin air
was only talked to talented students at
the new Travel Pettigrew uses
conjuration in 1996 and he produces
ropes which bound Harry Potter to Tom
Riddle seniors grave it has been stated
that the only former Transfiguration
more difficult in conjuration was human
Transfiguration which he also achieved
so in a way he was a master of
Transfiguration next we have potions
Peter under Voldemort's instruction was
able to produce both the rudimentary
body potion and the regeneration potion
the first potion allowed Voldemort to
achieve his basic rudimentary form and
the latter returned the Dark Lord to his
former glory
potions were highly advanced dark
magical potions which Pettigrew would
have had no experience with sure
Voldemort was probably a good teacher
but he still pulled it off successfully
and didn't pull a Seamus Finnigan Peter
also helped Barty Crouch jr. to produce
the Polyjuice potion which allowed
Crouch to assume the identity of Alastor
Moody a Polyjuice potion is described as
follows the Polyjuice potion which is a
complex and time-consuming concoction is
best left to highly-skilled witches and
wizards it enables the consumer to
assume the physical appearance of
another person as long as they have
first procured part of that individual's
body to add to the brew this may be
anything toenail clippings dandruff or
worse but it is most usual to use hair
this leads us to peter's next skill
dueling
despite Professor McGonagall expressing
in his younger years that he was
hopeless at dueling Patrick we went on
to become fairly successful in numerous
dueling endeavors as the Polyjuice
potion above-mentioned
in order to successfully produce one you
need to procure parts of the
individual's body in order to obtain the
ingredients necessary to impersonate
Alastor Moody Pettigrew had to try and
trap moody which he did along with Barty
Crouch jr. Alastor Moody was the
Scottish pureblood wizard and is
considered by many to be the most famous
aura of all time he is an order of the
Phoenix member dark wizard catcher in
warrior moody served with great
distinction during the first visiting
war and lots an eye like a nose in
battle against evildoers Moody is
personally responsible for a large
number of the witches and wizards in
Azkaban and this earned him quite the
reputation amongst the dark wizard
community nonetheless it was Pettigrew
and Barty Crouch jr. job to capture him
and this makes Pettigrew's achievement
capturing him all the sweeter
additionally though it wasn't much of a
jewel Pettigrew makes quick work of
Cedric Diggory with Avada Kedavra
though Cedric was young and didn't see
coming he was considered to be a
talented student and stood no chance
against Wormtail this also spoke to
Pettigrew skill in all manners of the
dark arts as Avada Kedavra is not
particularly easy spell to cast a
verdict d'oeuvre is one of the three
unforgivable curses and in order to use
it properly
it requires extreme concentration
additionally in 1981 the same year
Pettigrew framed Sirius for the death of
12 muggles you
a dark advanced and powerful blasting
curse the curse was strong enough to
murder 12 people destroy hundreds of
feet of sewer system and leave a 40-foot
crater in the ground I am certain that
Peter was far more knowledgeable and
skilled in the dark arts
then anew the other Marauders would be
in addition to the above-mentioned
which features some of his most notable
accomplishments Peter also helped to
produce and design the marauders map a
highly advanced piece of magic showed
extreme Wand versatility seemingly using
any and all ones that he got a hold of
with no issue despite not yet winning
the ones allegiance regularly used non
verbal magic ones and incantations
generally help witches and wizards to
channel their magic allowing the
pituitary or potent result however truly
powerful witches and wizards are able to
produce magic regardless of these two
things Peter Pettigrew was one of those
wizards so as you can see Pettigrew was
able to achieve a lot during his time in
a visiting world when I made the list of
them as powerful Death Eaters which you
can find in the description I included
Pettigrew as an honorable mention and
many of you questioned why to all of you
who questioned it this is why sure
Pettigrew is no Snape or Bellatrix or
dollar HOF and yes he was a traitor and
a coward of a man but he did end up
becoming a reasonably powerful wizard
and that's it for this video what do you
guys think are we missing something let
us know down in the comments section
below until next time you're a wizard re
[Music]
you